headed home job done but this is far
from mission success
the last british troops have withdrawn
from afghanistan following a two-week
evacuation effort
a difficult finale after two decades of
war and then the big question
was it worthwhile
the prime minister said
twenty years ago in the wake of the
september the eleventh attacks the first
british soldier set foot on afghan soil
aiming to create a brighter future for
the country and all its people
the departure of the last british
soldiers from the country is a moment to
reflect on everything we have sacrificed
and everything we have achieved in the
last two decades
the nature of our engagement in
afghanistan may have changed but our
goals for the country have not
we will now use all the diplomatic and
humanitarian tools at our disposal to
preserve the gains of the last 20 years
and give the afghan people the future
they deserve
that humanitarian spirit on display over
the past fortnight as british troops
pulled off the largest military
evacuation since the second world war
more than 15 000 people flown to safety
including british nationals and afghans
who worked for british forces and faced
threats from the taliban
but a u.s deadline of tuesday for this
u.s led mission to end
meant many more had to be left behind
desperate abandoned and that hurts i'm
afraid it's absolutely heartbreaking
that we can't bring everybody out
and i think that point's been made very
strongly uh certainly by the defence
sector and others over the last um 10
days or so
personally i've probably had
over 100 messages from different afghans
who i know in my long association with
the country and many of those um friends
of mine won't make it out and for me you
know not a day passes will be my without
me having a bit of a tear in my eye
about all of that this former
interpreter was blown up while on patrol
with british forces in 2007
now in birmingham rafi says hundreds of
colleagues are stuck in afghanistan at
fear of death from the taliban and with
no ability to escape without britain's
help going to a third country requires
passport visa
those things are pretty much at this
stage
impossible for them to get because there
is no functional government to issue
passport and these other countries are
at the moment as far as we know they are
unwilling to issue any visas for the
afghan nations you yourself you worked
with british forces in afghanistan you
were blown up
because of your service
how are you feeling now living in the uk
looking at what's happened to your
country i'm saying this on behalf of all
those afghans that
i'm in contact with and i'm echoing
their voices we feel betrayed by the
americans and nazi forces
we feel let down
in kabul it's over to the u.s forces to
hold the line before they too exit and
then what for this country
back under taliban control women's
rights again at risk and with a real and
present terror threat
just as it was back in 2001 when british
and american troops first arrived debra
haynes sky news